oui oui c'est maintenant devenu mais
vous y ait un prénom derrière amélie
comment amélie de vue
bailly simon connu sur le nom de me
juger
j'ai toujours resté le but vous faites
le ménage ici au 5e et ben ali n'a déjà
fait treize content bon ouais mais la
fac ressenti avec moi oui bah vous êtes
un petit peu particulière parce que vous
avez déjà fait des émissions de radio
d'émissions télé vous êtes un peu une
vedette
on n'appelle pas ça une vedette on
alterio c'est pas une vedette bon parce
que vous êtes très gentil c'est de
sauver mais c'est pas ça une vedette tu
ne veux être moi je fais ça quelqu'un
qui tourne des films dallas à la télé
avant quelqu'un qui parle à la radio
c'est pas une vedette en vue non pas par
fabrice rtl d'accord alors ça c'est dur
ça sa cellule moi je vais j'ai décidé
aujourd'hui de faire une interview un
entretien avec madame lui qui s'appelle
en fait amélie qui est la femme de
ménage du cinquième du cinquième étage
de la maison de la radio les tailles que
l'ina et voilà que voilà que madame lui
en fait elle écoute pas du tout pour
beaucoup france inter ni radio france l
écoute fabrice sur rtl alors ça commence
mal et en fait non en fait ça commence
bien
ça commence très bien ça commence très
très bien l'année en tout cas madame lui
elle vous dit ah oui qu'elle est une
vedette qu'elle a tourné dans des films
en fait elle a fait une longue émission
avec yann paranthoën yann paranthoën
c'est un technicien ici aussi c'est un
producteur d'émissions qui travaille
pour france culture notamment est un
très grand de la radio qu'on aime tous
et qu'on respecte beaucoup qui nous a
appris à tous peut énormément de choses
notamment à moi par exemple et il a fait
un grand portrait dans l'est dans le
cadre des ateliers de création
radiophonique sur france culture
un long et grand portrait de madame lucu
et moi j'ai pensé que c'était une bonne
idée pour commencer
l'année alors que des grandes
personnalités et les grands de ce monde
et viennent vous vous vous apportez des
voeux viennent nous dire ce qui va se
passer sur sept dans cet hexagone et sur
cette planète 2 pour cette année j'ai
pensé que c'était pas mal pour une fois
de faire un de passer une heure tout
entière avec une femme de ménage avec la
femme de ménage du cinquième étage de la
de la maison de la radio
c'est ça ça se passe tout simplement à
50 m de mon bureau
li na est dans un bureau de l'ida tout
simplement elle est madame madame lui
est assise en face de moi bien droite
dans sa blouse bleue bien proprette
elle est très mignonne avec très jolie
elle fait penser à toutes les mamies à
toutes nos mamies c'est la mamie delà de
la maison de la radio c'est la mascotte
elle est très aimé et elle aime beaucoup
les gens alors dit dans vous travaillé à
france inter radio france et que vous
écoutez rtl toute la journée
la valise julien lepers tout je note la
valise
en arrivant je dois gagner ah non non
pour la gagner la valise il faut écrire
un et moi je ne veux pas donner mon
numéro de téléphone
parce que ça c'est personnel voyons
savez mon numéro de personnel numéro
téléphone après j'aurai des coupures des
côtes et le décolleté et comme je suis
pas beaucoup la 1
alors on cherche à la maison ça le
dérange
ils mangent les montures l'armoire
pourra avoir le téléphone c'est unique
jeudi il doit vous m'avez dit madame
lulu vous m'avez dit oui ziti grand mère
oui je suis grand mère de trois petits
garçons et d'une petite fille
pourquoi rien grand-mère quand même
non non j'ai 60 ans quand même bah oui
oui je traduis vieillir c'est quoi vous
aurez là où travaille la nuit
nous travaillons de 6h30 à 10 heures le
matin 1 et le soir nous travaillons dès
5h30 là jusqu à 20h55 pas là bon c'est
pas trop dur nous ont pas du tout j'ai
une classe des choix vous devez payer
ah bon vous vous revendiquez pas en bon
dites moi alors moi je travaille à la
radio depuis quand même pas mal de temps
mais vous vous devez connaître la radio
d'une manière différente
oui c'est vrai je connais la radio des
manières différentes
j'ai connu j'ai connu arthur conte je
suis rentré depuis les géorgiens ont été
percutées les cards il était pdg qu'il
est rentré la facture pente gelée connu
là c'est moi je suis rentré là après
j'ai connu comment ça s'appelle gilles
bouleau jacqueline rodrigue est resté un
bon moment
alors là là comme la maison a commencé à
se déliter dépiauter tournée quoi
n'hésitez pas à ranger comme ça arrange
et maintenant